Unlike so many other nicknames for the police,
such as cops and the fuzz, this particular
term has a relatively well known origin.
You see, starting around the sixteenth century
“pig” began being used in English as a
derogatory term for people, whether police
or not, as it still sometimes is used today.
It took about three more centuries, but this
particular insult inevitably became a popular
nickname for oft-insulted police officers,
with the first documented reference to this
being in the Dictionary of Buckish Slang,
University Wit and Pickpocket Eloquence, published
in London in 1811.
In it, the pertinent line in question is:
“The pigs frisked my panney, and nailed
my screws.”
Meaning: “The officers searched my house,
and seized my picklocks.”
poindexterWhy “Poindexter” is Slang for
“Nerd”
“Poindexter” as a slang name for a nerdy
person comes from a particularly memorable
stereotypically nerdy character in the cartoon
Felix the Cat.
The character in question is the nephew of
Felix’s archenemy, the Professor, who is,
of course, named Poindexter.
Poindexter was first introduced to the masses
in 1959 in the cartoon version of Felix the
Cat shown on TV.
Over the years, he has typically been depicted
in a lab coat, wearing thick glasses, and
otherwise personifying stereotypical nerdom
in all its glory.
Despite having been around for decades, it
took another Hollywood creation to really
get the popularity of this slang term firmly
implanted into common vernacular, rather than
as a fringe moniker for nerds.
This occurred in the mid-1980s thanks to the
character of Arnold Poindexter in the 1984
Revenge of the Nerds.
Since then, “Poindexter” has been a relatively
popular moniker for anyone who exhibits extremely
nerdy tendencies.